well that sounds good
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
three big scary games scares big scares
huge scare energy on the scares you're
gonna love it because every time there's
a scare
you know that i care this is slide in
the woods there's a lot of stories about
like abandoned
playgrounds or like park structures or
like just buildings out in the woods and
i think that there's a subreddit
dedicated to kind of things like that um
and i would love for it if you guys have
any uh ideas or like stories of things
that are just found in the woods or if
you can remember what the subreddit is
that kind of has these kinds of things
right in the comments down below because
there is like this whole world of
previously built structures that have
just been reclaimed by the forest or
someone just decided hey we're gonna
build this random building in the middle
of the woods and
people will come surely
and then it just lies there rotten for
the rest of time
anyway this is about a slide in the
woods oh we're already here we're not
even gonna find it i found it already
hey
cool well
it's here i might as well have some fun
you know
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
we well that was fun okay that wasn't
that wasn't nearly as terrifying as i
thought it'd be but it was slightly more
terrifying than i expected a slide to be
but uh that's cool i can't go down the
pole
[Laughter]
it's pt in slide form we
i'm having so much fun going down this
slide
we know we where am i oh my god we oh
god
all right well then you know at any time
i bet i could
would you do that
oh
i found a flashlight
oh a lost flashlight luckily it still
has some battery left i bet
i bet it do
that was a bush i thought that was boots
i thought it was a pair of boots
okay
you know a little uh little nighttime
ain't gonna stop me from having a good
time on this slide here time to go again
who's watching me from the woods
why is this so weird
this is such like a normal thing well
it's not a normal thing for me a fully
grown adult to do
and also this slide is just randomly in
the middle of the woods
did my mom drop me off here
my mom just dropped whoa
oh
okay
yeah that's a thing that you stab and
just like get dropped off in the middle
of a playground you know in the middle
of some park somewhere and
you know we just me and my brother would
just play for a while
yeah
awk field news small town tragedy small
town is mourning in matt as mass missing
persons case at local park continues to
go unsolved reports say both children
and adults missing this slide is just
too much fun a detective working on the
case shed light on its peculiarity
stating it's as if they disappeared into
thin air he asks if anyone has any
information pertaining to the case or if
anyone spots one of the victims to
please contact local law enforcement
immediately
okay well
a depressing story like that isn't going
to stop me from having a good time
hey hey hey hey hey hey one at a time
one at a time on the slide
no one better be skipping the line it's
my turn it's always my turn
i'm the demon in the slide
what if i just slide down here and
there's gonna be something in the slide
there's gonna be something in this line
okay i'm fine
we
you can't have fun unless you say we
on the way down
okay
that's normal normal normal
hey hey hey
my turn you wait till i'm at the bottom
you wait till i'm about to bottom and
clear
all right someone's really someone's
really weighing doodling on that slide
oh
no
that's not good
what is that what am i looking at
what am i looking at what am i looking
what am i looking at
[Music]
well that looked like fun
no body bags getting dragged into the
slide
well covered with blood is gonna stop me
from having a good time
we listen to how much fun they're having
oh
no wait no hang on oh no oh no we we we
i say i'm winging
no wonder they sounded like they were
having such a good time okay anytime
there's a ba oh
this doesn't feel like a slide anymore
oh
crawl meter what do you mean crawl meter
crawl what
what
what what i am i am crawling
oh what do you mean what is that what
are you talking about
oh weird i'm crawling
apparently this is what crawling is
oh
why why
oh no please not be behind me oh no
something's behind sliding again
oh my god
oh my god screw
nothing cause i'm having so much fun
oh
i don't know if anything's behind me but
i'm not gonna look around i'm looking
no we're fine
nothing's fine nothing nothing's fine
everything's fine
so much fun
oh good
where am i oh
oh
again again
again i say
hip hip hooray
what a lovely day
ah again and again again
hey well oh that's not the slide
god just eager beaver was
too tempted oh oh
oh
[Music]
okay
oh wow okay
is this the heart of the slide is this
is what you're saying remove chain
but why though but but why would i do
that i could slide myself nah
i removed it
all right beating heart of the slide
apparently uh you're gonna go
into the slide you're gonna have a great
time
all right keep your arms tucked across
your chest
chin down
and uh remember to have fun
all right uh five four feed them
yeah okay
okay yep i'm gonna feed them apparently
honestly this looks like the best slide
of them all
[Music]
uh wait no hang on i wasn't supposed to
open this
oh no i can't move
oh no no no i was supposed to get my
reward
the slide um there's something coming in
here
oh no
oh good
oh good yeah this is what i want i'm not
gonna stick around and look i'm looking
oh what are you
what are you
i'm looking at you
what oh i'm not looking oh my god i look
too long
one at a time on the slide
one at a time
oh
no
anything but this current experience
no why is a slide suck ass
oh this is the worst slide
nothing like a clog on the goddamn slot
oh no oh no this is what you don't want
this is what you don't want okay all
right i'm not looking back
oh
we you know they're just having a good
time
as oh god damn it oh my god
oh my god i shouldn't look back i should
not look back i'm looking back oh i'm
not looking oh my god i have stopped
completely oh my god that was a dumb
idea why would i do that why would i do
that
okay oh my god please a little faster oh
my god a little more a little more a
little more really get the speed ah this
isn't the speed i'm stuck
oh my god
okay i really got that hill up
yeah i know i know i know it's super fun
definitely the funnest is
ramping up
and we
i bet this is the last one
i bet that's the last one
god damn it of course it's not the last
one
why would it be the last one
oh my god no
no
come on come on
there we go perfect
this has got to be the last one
that's it yeah you get away
you get away
oh oh
uh
am i blinking or is my flashlight dying
okay
we
i can finally have fun
on my slide
should i look behind me or something no
okay
oh why
oh
oh yay
lovely day
well let's go ahead
oh
mom
oh it's gone
i went on the wrong slide mom
i love that i loved that that was so
imaginative that was so cool that was so
cool legitimately that was just so cool
it was creative it was interesting it
was just plain old cool
i loved that it was different
like it did the repeating mechanic but
also it expanded upon it like took you
to some other place that was super cool
i liked that
that was fantastic
good stuff
i love that
great okay cool
good stuff man well done love that love
that
moving on this one looked weird
in a good way i think
it's hard to tell sometimes but this one
did seem like it was gonna be
very disturbing and very odd and also
it's getting dark
so that's even better for the moon
[Music]
oh hi
hi
oh
yeah i'm done working
i feel good about my day that i just did
i feel like i'm a girl
i don't like my office and in what world
would anyone set up their office so that
there's just an open gaping dark doorway
right behind you
i'm sorry
hmm
well i don't want to go down that way so
i'm going to go through the vent
which is a strange
preferable choice
having trouble
oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
how did you get in here
go through the door
closest to the desk
okay
i go through the weird void
please don't go in the vent again
go through the door behind you
i'm gonna go through the vent again i
don't know why but my stanley parable
instincts tell me hey can i go through
this thank you
yeah the stanley parable instincts tell
me to disobey you at every turn
i don't like following the orders of
voices through cameras
please don't go through the door
close to the desk i'm begging you it
would be so bad if you went through that
door
well is this reverse psychology i'm
gonna guess that's reverse psychology
and i'm gonna go to this one here
this door does not want to be effed
oh
you didn't go through
the door closest to the desk how is that
even possible
you're not programmed to spot lies oh i
am very good at that i'm very good at
that very good
okay i don't know what's going on
well i don't know what's happening
it's a little strange
i'm a little uncomfortable
not gonna lie
little uncomfy
also you said i was programmed am i some
kind of a robot why are you even trying
to escape
you know it's not possible
why would i even make it possible
i don't know why would you
why would you make it possible what
happens if i go back would anything
happen probably not
i'm gonna go through this door again
oh hey wow okay hi
steve you all right there buddy oh my
god you don't look so good
look what you've done now he's
completely broken
who
who's broken
why is he broken
i didn't mean i didn't that was not me
man not me
definitely not me
definitely not me all right later uh
steve
have a good day see you tomorrow
working hard or hardly working
uh hey
can you uh tell me how to get out of
here
that'd be great
what do you even
expect to happen
do you seriously think
i would just put in an exit
so that you could escape
i don't know who you are mr slow talker
i just know that i woke up
in front of a random computer
hi what's up
no then for you anymore
i removed it
and now
there's nothing
for you to do
other than work
later nerd
you can't
escape
you can only work
uh-huh sure
i'm very persistent i hope you know that
you can't
escape
you can only
work
um about that
like i said very persistent
you can't escape you can only work
what else we got going on here
no vent for you anymore i removed it and
now there is nothing for you to do other
din work well i guess i can only work
huh
all right i'll work
fine
oh
what
[Music]
is that what i get for disobeying is
that what i get for being an
that's probably what i get
that is probably what i get
hmm
all right let's try that again can you
please just get back to work
i'm tired of having
to find replacements
yeah so tired you're so
slow at talking
hmm
oh god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
what
i don't understand i don't understand
but
i'm going to leave that one there
because i don't know any other
alternative
okay well
not bad very confusing a little
unsettling but not terribly scary as i
would call it but not bad this is down
beneath
down beneath what i don't know
where down beneath i don't know that
either i don't know anything
i know nothing my head is completely
empty i'm gonna start a new game
why did i try to sit i'm sitting on the
floor right now by the way and i don't
know exactly
how to be comfortable i'm literally
sitting on a dog bed and my back rest is
up
it's it's it's a nightstand so yeah
hopefully i'm in frame still and if i'm
not ah
no i'm definitely not now hi hello hi
hello everything's fine don't worry
about anything everything's completely
fine everything's fine
always has been oh we will be let's go
down beneath oh gosh hi
okay
interact a box of syringe
yep
okay
the door is locked this is some kind of
an escape room hi grandma
oh
i don't like that
well
i got my tub of jello let me okay i
found a key dug my hand right into that
that don't bother me none
neither does the poop all over the
toilet
guess i'll just mosey on out of here
you unlocked the door i sure did
ha no
no ah yes no
yes
goopy
okay all right
i'm gonna assume you guys are all alive
is this a dead body i assumed wrong
continuing on my journey now
very goopy
what am i hearing
hello it's too dark you're goddamn right
it's too dark
maybe you could brighten things up a
little bit and not make it an ominous
red light
oh better thank you
ask a knee shall receive is that a
flashlight is that a flashy light in
this weird room that's an offshoot of
this weird goop hell
oh
cousin how you doing well
that's good found flashlight
nice very bright
very very bright
i can now go down that dark hallway that
i definitely
i'm gonna get you
i'm a monster now what if i'm scary what
if you're the little baby if you're the
screamy little baby what if i'm okay
i
i might be the screamy little baby
i might be
i might be the screamy baby
okay i'm gonna back away and i'm gonna
go down the hallway
this is gonna be good this is gonna work
out perfectly for me
this is gonna work out wonderfully hey
am i going around to meet that guy
no apparently not
oh door i like door
i love door
i love stairs i love stairs and door
uh okay good
great
oh i love back rooms i love the back
rooms
did anything ever come out come out of
the back rooms did any project actually
materialize for the back rooms or was
that just like this kind of weird rumor
that everyone talked about
oh good hey button you don't need to ask
me twice
oh yeah push the button no push that
button
i see a big red button i push it
immediately no questions asked what did
i just do the blue indicates an open
gate while the red indicates close gate
great
i want to open that gate but first i'm
going to see what's down this gate that
i just opened
oh
well i like door and i like stairs but
this door seems to be unusable
the door is blocked i could i i could
tell that from a distance
i didn't need to go up to it but i'm
glad i did anyway okay let's open the
bloody door why not why not why not i
shout to the heavens
push the button okay bloody door i love
the blood door i don't really like blood
i'm not gonna say i love blood but
no i'm not gonna say i love blood
there's no butt to that am i gonna try
to get a krober
oh great oh good um it's very dark
oh it is
wonderful
hi
well i hate this
reminds me of a game that i beat a long
time ago that i definitely didn't
abandon
oh what was the name of that wonderful
game that i beat for once and for all
and no one will ever bother me about
ever again
oh well it's slipped my mind
as i'm sure it slipped everyone else's
just looking for some tunnels on the
ground to crawl through for no
particular reason hi
hi
i don't like this
didn't mean to turn out my light there
didn't mean come on let's go let's go
all right good yeah
okay
obviously this room is occupied i will
leave you to it you have a good day now
you have a good day i'll try this door
blocked from the other side someone
wanted some privacy in there but that
other person did clearly clearly did not
kachuncus there's no power i wonder
where i could get power let me ask the
neighbor
hey you know where i could get any power
hey dude no
do you know where i could get some no
okay all right later
all right hey hey
[Applause]
what's with your toes
all right whatever i'll just be in here
don't mind me
yeah i'll pull it mind if i pull this
lever
yeah you did
okay looks like some sort of map yeah it
do
um but uh
but uh okay are they the same yeah
they're the same
yeah okay so straight
all right i'm gonna try to remember this
i'm gonna try to remember this because i
have a funny feeling i'm gonna be
running away from something as i try to
remember this i think i mean it seems
pretty easy this is pretty
straightforward that map's not hard hey
neighbor
maybe neighbor
where'd you go buddy where'd you go pal
all right anyway i'll just
i'll just act like nothing's wrong
hold the lever you
betcha well that sounds good
you would you would you would you oh is
this oh this is the uh this is the uh
thing isn't it this is the map is it oh
well
got it wrong from the get-go so i'm kind
of stupid
so i'm kind of stupid i just didn't know
which way i was coming into this thing
that's that was my problem that was my
problem okay all right well uh let's uh
let's uh let's mosey round the posies
one more time shall we uh let's uh let's
push up the daisies a little bit harder
this time why don't we
okay which way was the bad way was this
the bad way
was that the bad way oh yeah oh oh god
damn it i did the thing again all right
this way and then this yeah i got it now
i got it now don't worry about a thing i
know exactly where i'm going
then i ring around the rosie
my posies you know you know about my
posies
everyone knows about my posies
all right and then a straight shot to
the victory circle
definitely not creeping up behind me i
have plenty of room to run
oh this is my favorite room so far
what's down there nothing okay good i'm
gonna go in this door maybe
i shouldn't have even tried
that's what you get for being so goddamn
dull
can't even fit through a vent idiot
uh
graham graham i don't know
grandpa
ooh krober perfect that's exactly what i
needed
and i know exactly where to use it hey i
remember that from the beginning
grover i removed the planks with the
cribber
well time to run away i'm glad i went
down the door with the blood in it this
was just delightful
always a good decision when blood leads
you away
always a good decision okay hey my keen
sense of direction led me right where i
needed to be
and then i'm gonna go is it so dark that
you can barely see me
i hope so i hope it's that dark i hope
so i literally don't have any light in
here i have to go get light
eventually but i'm so lazy
all right let's so let's all push the
button
god i don't need to go that way okay
button has been pushed
now we got the door that we actually
need to go through which is great
i love that
and then
i remove the planks and i'm sure i'm
about to go right home
i'm about to go ride home
ooh dark
i love stairs i love door is that a door
up there is that a door you happen to
god damn it
okay well i can remove these
good glad to wonder why i did that oh
great yay
ah oh
good oh good good good
yeah let's see what happens oh boys why
oh god
activate all four levels no no no no no
okay
all right
sick
oh well that looks like something there
okay well the left opened okay and then
i saw a lever up tippy top of the left
yeah okay we got this oh oh that doesn't
sound good
that sounds distinctly bad
uh pull the lever yeah you sure why not
okay all right hey let's ring around the
rosie my dude
okay are we ringing around the rosie we
rosy ringing
we're rosying he okay i don't exactly
know what to do about the rest of the
the this
of the rest of the all of this
i don't know what to do about the rest
of the all of this
you know what i mean i don't really the
doors are kind of locked the doors are
kind of locked my dude
you're quick
i'm alive
i don't know what to do about any of
that i think i gotta go back and i think
i gotta open the door but i gotta ring
around rosie
listen can you forget that i ever
existed
that would be dope as hell that would be
super dope i have to how am i gonna i
don't know here i go
i did the thing
maybe it'll forget i'm here if i close
the door can i
you'll never know you'll never know
okay so it did open that one up there
okay that's good so i just gotta ring
around the rosie up there
throw that lever
and then be on my way okay i see you
come on
come on yeah come on yeah come on yeah
slowpoke come on come on
yeah yeah yeah okay and then ring around
the rosie
and then up top in this room off to the
left there is a ring around the rosy
spot
i don't know who built the security in
this place but it's really stupid i'm
just going to go ahead and say it's real
dumb
it's it's real dumb like real dumb oh
god it's top level dumb
it's like 99 highest iq levels of dumb
big dumb dumb
okay all right just gotta do one more
ring around the rosie and then i'm clear
kind of easy peasy
a little easy a little peasy
little easy little peasy hey come on
hey come on
easy peasy i'm right here come get me
come and get me
come get me
you can't even get me you couldn't even
get me if you tried and you just did you
loser you loser what a loser a loser all
right
pull the lever you know it baby
all right come and get me try me try to
get me try to get me you cannot you
cannot you're incapable of getting me
and then i just go
hey bud hey pal hey neighbor can you
stop the the dude you fight that dude
can you are you gonna fight that dude
oh yeah you keep him at bay
all right cool later man
i'm blind
the end
i win
it is very dark in here
you can't really see anything
it could be anyone here
could be anyone oh good
you can see me now
i like that it was pretty standard fare
for uh like when it comes to horror
games but it was very intricate you know
there was a lot of like interactivity
there was a lot of moving around it had
a monster which you know not not all
horror games these games do these these
days do have monsters um
and i liked it i thought it was pretty
cool it had some polish to it
the the the mechanics of like the escape
were enough to keep it engaging and
honestly i thought it was pretty good
not bad at all i don't know if there was
any story to it at all but
pretty good horror game and that's all
you can ask for so that was three scary
games thank you all so much for watching
hope you enjoyed it i know i did
i know i
did and i know you did
i know you did